[Music]
foreign
then for the Press preview a first look
at what is on tomorrow's front pages so
much to discuss tonight with Steve
Richards columnist and broadcaster and
Christopher hope associate editor for
politics at the Daily Telegraph they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight a very good evening to both of
you so let's have a look at some of
those front pages and they don't make
particularly happy reading Hunt paves
Way for years of pain as a headline on
the front of the Ft following the
Chancellor's Autumn statement
the metro rights that the budget
delivers the biggest Plunge in living
standards and highest tax burdens since
World War II
UK's lost decade is the headline on the
eye reporting that British earnings are
being sent back to 2013.
from bad to worse is the guardian's take
on the announcement made by the
chancellor
while the telegraph writes that
Britain's welfare bill is to rise by
almost 90 billion pounds after Jeremy
Hunt protects benefit claimants and
pensioners from soaring inflation
staying with the Autumn statement The
Daily Mail says middle earners and
Strivers were hammered with a stealth
tax squeeze years of tax pain ahead
leads the times
meanwhile Victory is the headline on
Express the paper leading on the
Chancellor's commitment to maintain the
triple lock on pensions
and the sun splashes on a story about
comedians David bediel and Frank Skinner
unveiling their new Christmas version of
Three Lions ahead of the World Cup
don't forget you can scan the QR code
that you see on screen join the program
check out the front pages optimize
papers while you watch us discussing
them and they're once again I'm joined
by Steve Richards and Christopher hope
really great to see you both um and what
an evening of front pages uh Steve we
were talking uh in the break you've
covered plenty of uh budgets plenty of
statements like this but I don't think
we've ever seen so many miserable front
pages have we no this is uh the worst
set of front pages I've ever seen
following budget stroke Autumn
statements and there have been quite a
few brutal gloomy budgets in their time
you know the early 80s some of those the
2010 Osborne austerity package and so on
but quite a few of those were greeted by
positive headlines the next day by
papers who sort of understood what these
various chances were trying to do this
with the exception of the express as
you've just highlighted uh is is
unequivocally
me and negative and I I think Chris and
I were both saying we can't remember a
set of front pages quite like this
following a budget yeah perhaps Steve
you have to delve a bit a bit further
inside the papers I see on the front of
the Ft Martin wolf is writing sanity has
been restored after the insanity of
quaten's mini budget and you have to say
the markets weren't ruffled Steve were
they today so they at least um are
seeing a glimmer of hope yeah and let's
also contextualize it in a different way
after the quasi-quarting mini budget
there were quite a few positive front
pages I remember the daily mail at last
a Tory budget and so on so it doesn't
necessarily mean
um that it will be as bad as these front
pages suggest in the same way Ken Clark
used to say when he was Chancellor a
budget that receives good press one day
starts unraveling a day later however
this is at the end of a long period of
conservative rule it's one of the
reasons why I think they are so no
negative when you're announcing such a
range of bad news and I think it's quite
ominous for this um long-serving
governing party these headlines yeah and
uh it's a particularly Grim headline on
the front of the Metro you've never had
it so bad I mean Chris uh what an eight
weeks it's been going from trophonomics
to this
yeah well I think it's seven weeks to
separate the um the statement for growth
from quasi quota and this and this uh
extraordinary mini budget if you said to
take one measure from it the 45p tax
rate that was abolished seven weeks ago
and it's been strengthened and made a
lot worse in court a lot more people in
this Jeremy Hunt mini budget announced
today it is extraordinary it's
bewildering
um it's confusing it's difficult to
comprehend Tory MPS are upset about the
language from Jeremy Hunt today they
think that the language that he used is
a language of Labor there was um very
little difference for summatory MPS
between what Gordon Brown got up to when
he was a Chancellor and what Jeremy
Hunt's done the language all said
language to describe unearned wealth
this language which is used for for
dividends uh for shares which have been
paid for out of people's earnings in
many cases and saved for
um it's been described in ways which
Tory MP has tell me they don't think a
conservative chapter should use those
terms
um there's a there's a real problem here
I mean I I say I was chuckling really in
a black humor way to what Steve was
saying about Ken Clark's remark about
budgets unravel the following day well I
mean if this one unravels any further
nothing left to be a piece of spring
well Chris it was funny I read your your
your column in the telegraph this
morning and you were saying vote labor
if you want to cut your income tax
and labor saying today you know this
this is the price of 12 Years of
economic mismanagement well I I said
that because I was I've been struck by
the past seven weeks since um Jeremy
Hunt reversed quasi-quartang's cut in
the base rate the 20p to 19p in income
tax uh that was reversed to 20p for the
Tory party and but labor have still have
their cut in place 20p to 19 piece so
vote if you want your tax cut vote labor
was and that showed to me showed well a
topsy-turvy world we're living in
politics when a labor is the party of
tax cutting not the Tory party
uh front of the eye uh says UK's lost
decade and the obr
um had a particularly Grim Outlook uh
Steve didn't they biggest drop in living
standards on on record um household
disposable income set to fall seven
percent over the next two years I mean
it's going to be really difficult for
people
yeah it is and you see again I think the
context is so important so that lost
decade when I saw the headline I wasn't
sure whether it was referring to the
last 10 years or the next 10 years
because it's been tough for the last 10
years and in a way the problem uh Jeremy
Hunt and uh Rishi sunak have got is the
only way you keep momentum going when
you've been in power for so long
um is to say look we've taken some
really tough decisions on Route
um but now we can see a sort of Promised
Land ahead you know after all the hard
tough times but they can't do that they
can only do the opposite and actually a
lot of the pain is postponed until 2024
onwards after the general election in
terms of spending cuts if if they were
ever to be imposed and of course on one
level that is a dream for labor because
they can say look this follows 12 years
of Tory government it doesn't follow a
labor government but it presents them
with dilemmas as well that degree to
which they challenge those spending
projections uh famously Gordon Brown
when Shadow Chancellor accepted all the
Tory proposed spending plans Post 97 and
after that election the then chance the
X chance to Kenneth classy had no
intention of keeping to them they were
ridiculously typed and I suspect that
would be the same if the Tories were to
get in next time but will labor dead
challenge them and face allegations the
opposite of what Chris has just said
hidden taxes and all the rest of it so
it's a dream on one level for labor but
some dilemmas to resolve from page of
the Daily Mail Chris echoing what we
were discussing a moment ago Sarah Vine
inside saying and there was me thinking
we'd voted in the conservatives
um the headline there tour is soak the
Strivers are very predictable headline
from The Daily Mail don't you think I
mean it is middle middle earners who who
are going to really struggle
we're getting stuck into the real
problem here for the Tory party uh this
uh front page in my own newspaper that's
Telegraph are absolutely brutal These
Are Meant To Be The Party The the papers
that support the consecutive party there
we have Sarah Vine of course the ex-wife
of Michael Gove saying and there was me
thinking we'd voted in the conservatives
and those bullet points there attack is
sort of higher since the war middle
class pundit in fund welfare and
pensions Tories soak the Strivers I mean
this is exactly what the Tory party
should stand for but is it it's the
complete opposite of what's happening
and when the Daily Mail turn on you it
is really difficult to come back from
this
um we'll come to the conservative
shortly the picture there of a very wet
Jeremy Hunt jogging this morning with
his dog somewhere where he lives in
central London
um you know he's a very he's a nice guy
a decent man Jeremy Hunt he was sold a
curveball difficult
um uh you know difficult case to answer
really once quality Cortana done his bit
and we are at the end of course of this
huge amount of money being spent on
covid-19
um the war in Ukraine Russia's Invasion
the energy shock it's a bit of a
nightmare for anyone in power but the
toys are being blamed for it and that
can only benefit labor yeah Steve I mean
how do you think this is going to go
down with the public we've talked a lot
about how back benches are going to see
and how business is going to see it but
how do you think the public are going to
take it on board do you think there's an
acceptance that furlough has to be paid
for covid cost the country a huge amount
of money Russia is a a problem that's
out of the government's hands
um uh they've got to clear up the mess
after after the quateng statement do you
think there is some sympathy for Jeremy
Hunt and for what he's done today
amongst the public
no
um by this point I think voters begin to
lose whatever patience they have
um because you know remember we've we've
talked about it we've already had the
sort of quasi-quartang period which is
this is an attempt to partly overcome so
it's quite hard for vote so oh yeah I
kind of completely up with what the
conservatives are doing when this is as
say an attempt to redress that
um and there are also issues to the
other contexts as well as this being a
long-serving government is that Britain
is doing worse on many measurements uh
compared with their European equivalents
um uh including in terms of growth
Britain's in recession now now why is
that what is distinct
um now in my view one of the issues is
brexit it's a sort of taboo theme but I
think it is beginning to surface that
not necessarily brexit but the version
of brexit negotiated by Lord Frosty
Frost as Boris Johnson used to call it
but there are others and so I think it's
quite hard
and they'll try and do it and say look
this is about Ukraine the pandemic and
all the other things that have gone on
it's an international challenge partly
it's but not holy and I think voters
have lost patience
Chris would you agree with that
well I would say you know in defense of
Jeremy Hunt he didn't make clear to MP
today how inflation is higher in
economies on the on the content
Germany's one I think you mentioned
um yeah I think there's it is difficulty
where they come back from I mean
bracketeers do tell me that the problem
with brexit not working is it's not
really understood or taken advantage of
by
um by by The Blob as they describe it
civil servants don't want to really push
the boat out and and grasp your the
opportunity given to them by the people
in 2016. I mean I think we can't really
relitigate brexit again but I I think
that that's part of the criticism from
the from the right of how brex has been
implemented
and and finally Steve the quandary I
suppose now for the government is is how
do you go for growth when inflation is
uh is soaring I mean did you see
anything in there that that sort of
pointed towards uh trying to grow the
economy as you say we're we're we're
lagging right at the end of the G7
countries
yeah well there were a few things but
they were relatively minor and when you
are imposing such constraints on public
spending
taking money out of the economy with tax
Rises uh growth is a kind of Fairly
distant Prospect and so I don't think
there was much it was such a contrast to
the quateng statement
growth growth growth tax cuts I mean
there's not I think this was managing a
crisis and perhaps making it worse okay
uh thanks for the moment we're going to
take a quick break coming up after that
more of the press preview including this
story from the telegraph the rhetoric of
Osborne with the policies of brown don't
go
[Music]
welcome back to the Press preview
Christopher and Steve still with me
front of the Daily Telegraph uh Chris
I'll let you do this is it's your paper
they their headline is a quote and I
can't actually find out who it's from
you might know the rhetoric of Osborne
were the policies of brown
yeah it's a quote from the resolution
Foundation which often provides very
good analysis of of budgets and Autumn
statements and and it's summarized I
think the way that there's two things in
play here I mean uh there's a there's a
kind of um Osborne trap maybe for labor
as Steve alluded to a little earlier
when he talked about how the fact that
the labor will have choices to make it
the next election whether to carry on
with these uh the spending cuts planned
by the Tories if they win or indeed not
to do that and how will they pay for
them
um but I think they've they've zeroed in
on on part of the problem at the heart
of this statement is is the way that the
government is protecting
um the welfare bill is up by 90 billion
pounds as hunt protects pensioners on
the state pension against inflation and
then clobbers which is not a word rough
and ease on the front page a telegraph
clubbers workers uh with tax Rises and
that seems to be the problem you go back
to the the last front page we looked at
Daily The Daily Mail and the Strivers
being hit there's a problem here that
seems at work isn't paying and that is
really that's why I think people think
well why is this a Tory government why
are they doing this
um It's A Hard choice for Jeremy Hunt
he's trying to protect people who can't
afford who can't get work or can't
afford to work and the rest of it but it
is a problem here because it's not
rewarding the right people for the
conservative party yeah um Steve I mean
it wasn't all bad news today was it uh
more money for schools more money for
the NHS more money for social care to
get people through these these tough
times and as the Daily Express
highlights uh the triple lock as well
good good news for pensioners
yes although it's interesting so far in
our review of the front pages we focused
on the tax Rises I think really of
Greater concern or what should be of
Greater concern to uh voters in the
country is the public spending plans
um now I know he didn't Jeremy Hunt put
it all on or most of it on public
spending cuts as George Osborne did in
2010 he did more on tax Rises certainly
in the short term but these spending
projections even for the NHS and
education which did get more than most
people thought it would
um is still relatively
alone compared with the demand the NHS
in particular I still think is going to
be a big story than a barn the waiting
lists
um even with this sort of ring fenced
funding so there is an issue to be
honest
um as to whether they are planning to
spend enough and certainly post 2024
2025 I mean they will hope that the
economy if they are still there the
economy is improving and they won't have
to do some of the spending constraints
but they are really tough so that's the
other side of the this particular rather
Bleak equation yeah okay it is it is a
bleak equation so let's finish on some
good news it's coming home Chris front
of the Sun
uh yeah the song which I remember I was
a goodness sake that it must be nearly
30 years ago in his first song song with
first of the charts
um uh is coming home by dealing skin of
course it's now got some Christmas words
because we have got a Christmas World
Cup and uh
um the top right there the sun next to
the mouth said tax hell thank God for
footy well Allen lead you to that
absolutely right um and the front of the
telegraph has a Mac cartoon uh which I
just want to bring up as well because it
sort of combines in in in the only way
that Matt can the awesome statement with
the football uh there's a couple
watching the Autumn statement on TV and
Matt says look on the bright side all
the bad news will prepare you for the
bitter disappointment of the World Cup I
mean let's hope not Steve come on
yeah but we I think partly enjoy being
miserable over the world cup I mean what
do you think we can drown up drown our
sorrows in The Round Up to Christmas all
right thank you both very much uh we'll
speak again Steve and Chris are staying
with us for the next hour to discuss
tonight's news and tomorrow's headlines
right now let's take a look at the
weather